plus d'un million trois cent cinquante
mille enfants vivent toujours dans la
pauvreté au canada selon le rapport
annuel du réseau campagne 2000 cela
représente 18,6 pour cent des enfants
presque un enfant sur cinq
ce réseau regroupe plus d'une centaine
d'organisations au canada et affirme que
les données officielles sous-estiment
l'étendue de la pauvreté la situation
s'est légèrement améliorée depuis 20 ans
en raison notamment de la mise en place
de l'allocation canadienne pour enfants
c'est au québec que le taux de pauvreté
le plus bas 15,2 pour cent grâce surtout
aux garderies subventionnées le minent
le manitoba affiche le plus haut taux de
pauvreté chez les jeunes
jean michel cousineau et économiste
professeur titulaire à l'école de
relations industrielles de l'université
de montréal bonsoir monsieur cousineau
françois fillon vous avez été membre du
comité de direction du centre d'études
sur la pauvreté l'exclusion du
gouvernement du québec vous avez regardé
ce rapport aujourd'hui qu'est ce que
vous en pensez mais j'en pense que c'est
une contribution
on s'appuie sur de nouvelles données
statiques canada a mis en place en 2010
8 tonnes nouvelle façon de calculer la
pauvreté et ça nous informent sur des
choses qu'on peut pas savoir l'avant on
savait des choses ou par la rouge par
sexe sur deux shows maintenant alors de
l'information sur les autochtones on
peut identifier des groupes qui sont
plus vulnérables et à ce titre là c'est
une contribution au niveau de
l'information et il y à des groupes il
ya des segments de la population plus
pauvre que d'autres et des disparités
géographiques également tout à fait oui
on vient d'avoir sa confirme qu'au
québec on a le taux de pauvreté selon
cette mesure là le plus bas on
identifier les autochtones les premières
nations où il ya des difficultés
las pour la première fois des chiffres
vraiment rompu on peut agir on peut
connaître la profondeur on peut
connaître les chiffres on peut savoir où
est ce qu'ils sont ce qu'on peut pas
avoir ce qu'on n'avait pas auparavant
avec les anciennes information est ce
que ça va nous aider à mieux lutter
contre la pauvreté infantile et donc je
retourne la question est-ce qu'on a des
faiblesses dans notre lutte parce qu'on
avait promis à 30 ans de régler le sort
de la pauvreté infantile à l'an 2000 on
n'y est pas arrivé quand même tout à
fait tout à fait il ya des progrès qui
doivent être faits
mais il faut pas sous-estimer non plus
je regardais les comparaisons là et de
groupes d'âge et la pauvreté a diminué
en nombre absolu il y avait je peux 1.7
million de choses comme ça de personne
dans un bazar qui était sous le seuil de
pauvreté ça a baissé 1.4 si je regarde
les autres groupes il ya eu des
augmentations je regarde les personnes
de 65 ans et plus il y en avait 2 196 me
l'an 2000 il y en avait huit cent trente
quatre mille en 2010 donc c'est vraiment
il baisser en nombreux surnoms absolue
et en taux et c'est le groupe qui ont eu
la baisse les plus importants mais chez
les aînés on a vu une pauvreté augmente
en jeu grâce à votre émission où j'ai pu
constater dans allant fouiller qu'il ya
aussi d'autres groupes qui ont connu des
difficultés particulières
cela dit restons un petit peu sur les
enfants doit-on dire qu'on atteint nos
objectifs si on voit le nombre absolu
baissé et le taux baisser mais qu'on dit
quand même que presque un enfant sur
cinq vit dans des pauvres tout à fait il
faut poursuivre et c'est une bonne façon
de poursuivre pour ça que cela par là va
être utile je pouvais au gouvernement
pour les syndiqués des pistes de
solutions il y en a dans le temps la
part des pistes de solution en termes de
concertation avec les autochtones en
termes d'accès aux allocations aux
canadiennes pour enfants qui sont pas
universels iliad est tous un peu partout
il leur a parlé les identifier il ya des
familles
justement parce que les locations
canadienne pour enfants dans le rapport
on dit que ça a permis d'éviter à plus
de 680 4000 enfants âgés de moins de 18
ans de vivre en situation de pauvreté en
2010 mais certaines familles vulnérables
n'en reçoivent pour comment les
impossibles tout à fait c'est un défaut
qui est identifié là il faudrait
voir à ce que cela soit corrigé d'après
moi c'est quelque chose qui peut être
vite fait bien fait oui mais est-ce
qu'on fait dit est ce que le
gouvernement en fait assez quand même
parce que ce gouvernement a dit que la
location canadienne pour enfants et être
un pas important qui avait sorti
beaucoup de jeunes la pauvreté oui est
ce que le gouvernement fait assez bien
là il y en a fait plus que beaucoup
d'autres gouvernements et on voit les
résultats aujourd'hui
alors ça ça veut dire que si poursuit
dans cette voie là bien il va y avoir un
rayonnement des améliorations encore
davantage pour le pour le futur donc
risquer des recommandations qui nous
amène plus loin banques comptent en
l'air pour par exemple l'allocation
universelle de la location canadienne
pourra faire la rendre universellement
d'accès bas tout le monde vers et de
concertation et à reporter les budgets
qu'il faut pour les autochtones
on vient d'apprendre que c'est assez
important qui ont peu de mesure et puis
évaluer les répercussions des politiques
qui vont être faites il ya de quoi du
côté du logement qui est assez ciblé par
contre si on veut à côté tout seul on
dit qu'il ya des gros qui sont très
vulnérables puis leur côté on recommande
parfois des mesures qui sont tout azimut
la facture on y voit avec soins
dentaires et de médicaments pour tous
assurance médicaments pour tout le monde
garde un oeil à tarif réduit pour tout
le monde je pense pas que le
gouvernement l'opus faire tout en même
temps
mais ce sont des mesures qui
permettraient de sortir beaucoup de
jeunes la pauvreté cela oui mais si on
les donne à tout le monde il ya un
paradoxe qui vient d'apparaître
parce que là si on a enrichi la classe
moyenne ont vieilli par cette mesure là
d'augmenter nombre de pauvres parce que
les pauvres ce défi de se définissent en
proportion de la richesse des classes
moyennes dans la classe moyenne monte
bien évidemment par définition sont
organisées on donne pas aux eaux que
plus de peau or le gouvernement aux
prises avec soit améliorer la situation
de la classe moyenne ou soi permettent
aux jambes aux revenus d'accéder à la
classe moyenne et ce rapport-là
travaille dans ce sens de donner accès
aux gens plus pauvres à la classe
moyenne
voilà tout à fait merci beaucoup pour
cette analyse monsieur cousineau témoin
vous remercie